نحن هنا في مخيم المغازي وسط قطاع غزه
وهذا مربع سكني دمرته الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه وسوته بالارض عده منازل طالها
الدمار والضرر جراء هذه الغارات التي
نفذتها الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه بعد
منتصف الليل عندما شنت سلسله من الغارات
واحزمه ناريه استهدفت هذا المكان وهذا
المربع السكني كما نرى هذا دمار كبير حل
بكل هذه المنطقه التي كان يتواجد فيها ع
شرات من السكان والنازحين الذين لجوا الى
هذه المنازل منازل اقاربهم منازل الجيران
رغم كل ذلك قصفته الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه بعد منتصف الليل عندما كان
بعضهم نائما وبعضهم لجا الى منزله
وبالتالي كانت المنازل مكتظه عن بكره
ابيها فبغ تتهم الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه بهذا القصف المفاجئ
وسقطت عددا من القنابل على هذه المنازل
وهذا المربع السكني فدمرت وسوت عدد من هذه
المنازل بالارض وربما نلتقي مع احد
الناجين هنا وربما هو الناجي الوحيد من
هذه العائله ايش اللي صار عندكم فاجاه
احنا
تعشينا تعشينا وكنا قاعدين في الصاله هذه
فاجاه ما شفنا الا ه الدنيا بته علينا
اجوا الناس وطلعو من من هذك الجهه واخوي
خطيره بقى هناك واهلي كلهم لسه تحت عم
وابوي واخوتي اولادهم وزوجاتهم لسه تحت ال
تحت الرد بهين الله الحمد لله على سلامت خ
عظم الله اجركم اذا هذه الغارات
الاسرائيليه باتت مكثفه على المنطقه
الوسطى لا سما ان ايضا انها استهدفت عدد
من المنازل في مخيم البريج كذلك وكذلك
استهدفت الطرق المؤديه ما بين مخيم البريج
ومخيم المغازي ايضا قصفت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه مدخل مخيم المغازي وبالتالي
بات الحركه والتنقل بين المناطق الوسطى هي
مهمه صعبه هذا الدمار الكبير ايضا حل
بالكثير بالعديد من المنازل والكثير من
المنازل في مخيم النصيرات ومخيم البريج
اذا هذه الحرب الاسرائيليه مستمره
ومتواصله وتستهدف في جل استهدافها
المدنيين الفلسطينيين ومنازل مدنيه
فلسطينيه تدمرها على رؤوس سكانها هشام
زقوت الجزيره من مخيم المغازي وسط قطاع
غزه فلسطين